the fans want closure bro i talk to them
every single day on twitter now you're
super active they want closure bro they
want to know why how you know if we put
the fans are the fifth member of
slaughterhouse if we ever put them first
class house would have came out
everybody put ego and pride first
that's why glasshouse never came out
it's that simple like if you had to
really it sounds like
and again
it sounds like if it weren't for joe
budden the album would have been out
hey dawg am i crazy yo listen joe
retired he said it on his podcast no i i
they can go and do whatever
i'm trying to tell you i think see royce
is a
a music he's a heavy heavy music guy so
in his mind he probably has this album
this this crazy album that he knows that
we can achieve as a as a group that he
wants to you know
help
he he wants to paint this picture he
just probably has so many ideas when it
comes to slaughterhouse that he wants to
do but what he doesn't understand is is
that
it's not gonna get done bro yeah i mean
listen we've it's 10 years bro
i feel sad every time i see him talking
about he was going to get joe to rap i'm
like dude he was never going to rap i
mean listen rice is one of the greatest
of all time yes absolutely i think when
you're royce and you
put out i mean the book of ryan and then
the allegory got nominated for rap album
of the year
probably the two best bodies of work of
his career absolutely
i'm not sure like if you're royce like
the headache or the it's just a lot like
it sounds like the whole slaughterhouse
thing is a lot
it is and
anything when there's four moving parts
four new four people ever you got a
manager yeah he's got a manager he's got
a manager we all got four lawyers it's
just it's a lot and if and and you know
for me like
i just had always assumed this [ __ ] was
a wrap forever when joe retired right i
was just like oh well now see you assume
that yeah well now you you're like no
we're gonna put an album out and let you
know it's a wrap yeah yeah i mean
because because there's your guys's fans
are a certain type of
cult
following where they're they're until
they get the final no they're gonna keep
harping on the situation they're very
invested in to slaughterhouse they are
very invested you know what i'm saying
and i don't think in this whole
debacle nobody is
nobody's caring about i mean i even
heard joe say the fans are idiots i'm
like dog listen
um when we was on tour
i'm the last man on the tour bus
first man off
i'm out there with the fans we get off
the stage i'm taking pictures with them
i'm signing autographs i'm doing shots
with the fans we talking rap you know
what i'm saying that's just who i am
these are the people who love what we
love these are the people who put us
where we are you know what i mean and
i'm out there showing love having fun
with the fans at all times so i've
always been that type of person and it
doesn't stop because slaughterhouse
stops you know what i'm saying so when
the fans hit me and they're like yo you
we you know i was listening to your song
goodbye and you know my uncle died of
cancer too and man it just really it
saved me from wanting to harm myself and
just know that you're going through the
same thing and all that i take that [ __ ]
to heart that [ __ ] ain't just a comment
on my [ __ ] screen on my screen that's
[ __ ] real [ __ ] and i take that [ __ ]
to heart and when they tell me they want
to know what the [ __ ] is going on with
the music and why we ain't putting out
no records and what happened to
slaughterhouse i want to give them that
closure too look this is what happened
now i'm not going to go super deep and
dig up all kind of [ __ ] and show you
where the bodies are i'm just going to
be like yo this is what happened and you
know thank you for all your support over
the [ __ ] years i'm sorry to be the
bad news bad news i'm sorry to be that
guy but this is what the [ __ ] happened
it's over and some of the best
[ __ ] movies are based on a true
story this is a true story period